>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Jason Steinhauer: Well
good afternoon thank you.
My name is Jason Steinhauer,
I'm a program specialist
at the John W Kluge Center
at the Library of Congress.
Today's lecture is presented
by the John W Kluge Center
at the Library of Congress.
The Kluge Center is a vibrant
scholar center on Capital Hill
that brings together scholars and
researchers from around the world.
To distill wisdom from the Library's
rich resources, to stimulate,
energize one another and to interact
with policy makers and the public.
The Center offers opportunities
for senior scholars,
postdoctoral fellows and PhD
candidates to conduct research
in the Library of Congress
collections.
We also offer free public
lectures, conferences,
symposium and other programs.
And we administer the Kluge Prize,
which recognizes outstanding
achievement
in the study of humanity.
For more information about
these and other events,
please sign our email
list on your way out
or visit our website
loc.gov slash Kluge.
Today's lecture is titled Imagining
the Amazon, European Colonialism
and the Making of Modern
Day Amazonia.
Our speaker is Anna Browne
Ribeiro, now completing her tenure
as a Kluge fellow at
the John W Kluge Center.
For the past decade Browne Ribeiro
has engaged in archeological
and ethnic graphic research
in the Brazilian Amazon.
With a particular focus
on anthropogenic
or human made landscapes of
the deep and recent past.
At the Kluge Center, she is working
on her book project entitled
Rethinking Empty Places,
An Archeology of Amazonian Dwelling.
Which revises notions
of tropical forests
by combining archeological
evidence with critical rereadings
of early accounts of
European travels in Amazonia.
Her talk today examines how in
spite of archeological evidence,
that counters such narratives,
the language of colonialism,
shaped and continues
to shape how the Amazon
and Amazonian peoples are
depicted, conceptualized
and most importantly managed.
Anna Browne Ribeiro is Co-Director
of the Interdisciplinary Project,
origins culture and environment
housed at NPEG in Brazil.
In 2013 she was awarded funding
by the National Geographic Society
for her project history
of a crossroads an
Amazonian city in deep time.
Her current work intro leaves
deep historiography of Amazonia
and tropical places with
data driven geoarcheological
and anthropological
research with a focus
on human environment interactions.
Brown Ribeiro received her PhD
in anthropology at the University
of California Berkeley in 2011.
Was a social and biological
sciences postdoctoral fellow
at the Ohio State University
from 2011 to 2013.
And then moved to the NPEG
as a postdoctoral fellow
bridging the cultural anthropology
and archeology departments.
She has published in the
Journal of Archeological Science,
Latin American Antiquity and
Archeological Review from Cambridge.
And has contributed
chapters to edited volumes,
dealing with travel writing.
For the past seven months,
she has been a Kluge
Fellow at the Kluge Center.
So please join me in
welcoming Anna Browne Ribeiro.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
>> Anna Brown Ribeiro:
Can everyone hear me?
Yes, okay.
So first of all I wanted to thank
Jason for that amazing introduction.
And also the Kluge Center for
offering me the opportunity
to come here and sit down and
read and write and get a feel
for the history of ethical
part of the research
which is something I don't normally
get to do, when I'm out in the field
or teaching classes in Anthropology.
Of course the Library of
Congress, anyone that works here,
the collections officers, the people
at the maps room who have helped me
for the past few months, gather data
that I'm going to be
presenting today.
As an archeologist of course
I love maps, so we're going
to be seeing a lot of maps today.
And the Kluge Fellows who've offered
an amazing environment for me.
Both the ones that are here and
ones that were here last semester.
They have really helped
me to open up the way
that I think about these histories.
And of course thanks to all of you
for coming and being here today
to hear me talk about my research.
Amazonia is a place
that is I will show you.
Has been profoundly misunderstood in
it's history and it's functionality.
This has had grievous
consequences for the environment
and for the people who live there
and potentially for the world.
What I'm presenting here, I could
never have envisioned ten years ago,
when I first went to the Amazon.
In fact, it took me a year and
a half from my first return trip
to actually understand that I
wanted to go back and why it was
that I wanted to go back.
It's oddly fitting that I should
be here presenting the research
from my first book on the Amazon.
At the Kluge Center, a
place that was made possible
through the generosity
of John Kluge.
Who as it happens also created
the fellowship program that got me
to the Amazon in the first place.
How things circle back.
So let's take a look at the Amazon.
And I've purposely created this
blank slate for us to look at.
Just to situate everyone, this
is northern South America,
Brazil, Colombia, Peru, Bolivia.
Amazonia has historically
been portrayed.
Hang on a second.
As places excessively fragile and
primordial or a savage forest.
This is made plain in debates over
how to conserve, preserve or talk
about responsibilities
for this place.
However, the idea of preserving
or reputedly pristine landscape,
though appealing to
some, must be revised.
In light of evidence archeological
and ecological that shows us
that the Amazon has been
very very much modified
over the last 2,000 years through
human and natural processes
and usually the two
working in conjunction.
The pristine forest that
was at times romanticized
and at a times demonized by
European writers, is a myth.
I explore the roots of
these misconceptions.
We're going to trace the emergents
of the pristine forest myth
through discovering
narratives, enlightenment thought
and later anthropological writing.
These institutions sedimented these
ideas in Western thought and I argue
and I think you'll probably
see, that they continue
to impact the way we think
about the Amazon today.
During this sort of revisionist
work, understanding the things
that lie at the roots
of our misconceptions,
help us to revise our
assumptions and think
about different possibilities
for Amazonia.
Part of understanding
this is understanding
of the landscapes constructed people
at the same time people
constructed landscapes.
The European travelers
that took it all in,
they understood certain kinds
of landscapes to be inhabitable
and other kinds of landscapes not.
Their first reaction,
their first contact
with Amazonian landscapes I argue
is what eventually the shaped
that we see it today.
These are what I call the
roots of these misconceptions.
My work engages with a broader
anthropological approach to place.
As well as with fundamental
methodological issues surrounding
narrative, model building
and representational troughs.
I find place to be a useful concept
because it requires an embodied
understanding of human existence,
that means we exist in our
bodies, our minds are not separate
from our bodies, we
experience the world
as material beings
in a material world.
In the words of Edward Relph, a
humanistic geographer who is writing
in the 70's, place is primal.
It arises momentarily and
makes us as we make it.
In other words, people,
places and times, events,
actions are co-constitutive.
This means that places are
also historically contingent,
at every moment a place
isn't what it was before
and it's never going to be the same.
They're meaning latent,
someone has to perceive a place
to define this as what it is.
We're continuously remaking
the world, re-signifying it
and we're always in place.
But since the 1970's anthropologists
and archeologists have become
increasingly interested
in the notion place, as the
meeting laden and contingent idea.
Drawing upon social theory
and philosophies scholars
like Tim Ingold, Barbara
Bender, Margaret Rodman
and Charles Cobb have explored the
power of places and landscapes.
Considering the material of
conditions of our encounters
with the world, it's critical
to understanding the past.
It's critical to understanding as
populated, not as a place frozen
in them, devoid of human intention.
It's important to consider humans as
agents, people that were thinking,
that were learning, that were
deciding whether to continue
on a path or to change
their actions.
And that they have
their own histories
and their own understandings.
But most importantly, it helps us
to comprehend out own encounters
as scholars with the
locations that we visit.
And so that we know or at
least have an awareness
that we might be seeing
things in a particular way.
There's a figure missing.
Okay well I was going to propose,
that what we're going to learn
about the Amazon is that
there's a different kind of order
to that place, an order that
wasn't was envisioned by Europeans.
Europeans were use to
certain kinds of landscapes,
they had come up in agrarian
societies and tempered places
and understanding the
ecology of a place
like the Amazon wasn't
something was going to be easy.
And they were also coming to
the Amazon with particular ideas
about the what the tropics or the
tourism could or could not support.
And they generally thought
about that as uninhabitable.
And the idea of uninhabitability
is really crucial
to understanding why the Amazon is
treated the way it's treated today.
And why those ideas if
shifted, could change the way
that our future is
entangled with its future.
The first half of my talk, is
going to deal with these encounters
and I'm going to focus a lot on the
maps, the materials that I got here.
They've added a lot to my
understanding of the Amazon.
I wish I could show you all
of the maps that I've found.
But I'm just going to, I'm
going to do a little snapshot
and I'll be happy to talk about some
of the other findings
that I had afterwards.
And then the second half of my talk,
I'm going to through a
quick archeological example,
that comes from my PhD
dissertation research.
Through which I construct
an embodied account
of life in the Amazon.
And the way that I was able
to understand how a
landscape was transformed
through human action it was
completely and entirely contingent
on thinking about people as sentient
beings that could perceive things,
could understand things and could
make decisions about how to proceed.
Slight disclosure I think
Jason already told us a little
about this but, I come
from historiography
and I come from geoarcheology.
And for those of you who don't
know what geoarcheology is,
it's the application of
earth science methods
to archeological work.
And I focused mostly on soil science
methods because as you will see,
understanding the soils of
the Amazon was essential
to understanding why
certain choices were made,
both by Europeans and by Amazonians.
In terms of a kinds of
resources they would use
and the how they would
inhabit or not this landscape.
And so which Amazon?
The Amazon is a complicated thing,
because it's not just one thing.
The Amazon is several things.
In fact I usually the
term the Amazon,
to talk about this imagined place.
Because it can be the Amazon River,
the forests that are immediately
next to the Amazon Channel,
it could be the drainage basin
of which is pictured here.
But that's problematic because it
excludes the Orinoco River Basin
which is actually it shares
a watershed with the Amazon
as you'll see in the next image.
It also excludes the Guianas
have very similar landscapes
but drain entirely to
the north and the east.
This is an excellent example
of a different configuration
of the Amazon.
It's a study done by NASA
scientists on the way
that trees green in dry periods.
So they're literally collecting
light information and creating a map
of the greenest portions of South
America during the dry season.
And what we see looks like
a contiguous thing except
that the line at the
very top of the Amazon,
just above Colombia is
actually the Orinoco River.
So we're including half of the
Orinoco River Basin in the Amazon
and the other half we're excluding
because of green patterns.
So Amazonia is really a shifting
landscape and the more that I travel
in Amazonia and the more that
I read, the more I realize
that it's not just forest.
It's savanna's, it's swamps
and these things are
changing as climate changes.
Which is something that we
have to become attuned to.
And which is also why it's
important to think about the Amazon
as inhabited because if you live in
a place, then you know what it does.
And you're not likely to
treat it like any other place.
Many times the solutions
that people apply
to using the Amazon today are
these Pan-Amazonian solutions
that really don't work
in most places
because at best they were
tested in one location.
So we're really not
talking about one Amazon.
We're talking about many
Amazon's that overlap,
expand and contract over time.
So let's talk about
the myth of the Amazon.
As Neil White had pointed
out the very fact
that we call it the Amazon
should tell us something.
And the very elusiveness
of Amazonia on the ground
as an entity that can't be bounded.
Or as I would put it, our insistence
that such an Amazon must exist.
Makes it a place that
must be imagined.
Let's look at how we've imagined
it in contemporary times.
The largest rain forest
on Earth has been touted
as the lungs of the world.
A global air conditioner and
as an essential carbon sink.
Of those global ecosystems
services Amazonia has been said
to provide only the
last seems to be true.
And apparently diminishing.
The other two functions are myths.
And apparently the need
for myths is great.
As far as Amazonia is
concerned at least.
Mythologies arise, circulate,
diminish and often come back
to haunt us and they will today.
Regardless of whether these myths
are true, they serve a function.
They tell us today why we should
care about a place that seems
so very very far away in
both space and in time.
Thanks to these myths we have an
awareness that Amazonia is important
to the future of the
Earth in some way.
Whether it has to do with
environmental preservation,
climate change, conscious
consumerism
or on occasion indigenous
or human rights.
These particular myths
also tell us something
about our ideas about Amazonia.
That it's still possible to locate
the magnificent and the horrifying
in a place we have known
for nearly 500 years.
Known but not understood.
Occasionally I do a search on
the internet for the Amazon.
And after I've filtered through all
the search results for the site,
I usually come up with
images like these.
People advertising it's nature or
people calling for it's salvation.
Rarely do we see pictures of people.
But people made the Amazon.
So we need to rethink this.
And when I first traveled to
the Amazon, even though I knew
that I was going to an archeological
dig and I knew that I was going
to be excavating things
that people did,
I still had these images in my head.
And I think a lot of us
do or a lot of us hope to.
And that's something to explore
and that's something that's kind
of beyond the scope of what I do.
But I just want to
throw that out there.
I remember thinking, on the
plane, I'm going to the Amazon.
I'm going to the Amazon.
How cool is that.
So I want to talk about that
Amazon, that mystical mythical place
that we learn about in school
and through film and even
through reputable news outlets.
How did this place come to be?
Even on the map the Amazon
was discovered and labeled
as the sweet sea in 1500.
It wasn't until February of 1541
that people understood
it as a river.
It was in that month
that Gonzalo Pizarro,
then governor of [inaudible] a
province located in modern day Peru,
went in search of the fabled land
of cinnamon, [foreign language].
There he hoped to extract at
a fraction of a cost a spice
that could be valued on a par with
the coveted Sri Lankan cinnamon.
And in the enthusiasm of the
day, Pizarro saw the new world
as the land of opportunity.
And sought not only
the land of cinnamon
but also the fabled
city Manoa or El Dorado.
El Dorado is one of the names
of the fabled city of gold.
Also known simply as Dorado,
Manoa del Dorado, Parime, Patiti,
the lake of gold, the castle of
gold and several other names.
El Dorado features in discovery and
scientific narratives for centuries
as late as the 18th century.
So what we're looking at here,
is an archeological object.
That's attributed to the muisca
people and they were known
in Colombia apparently legend has
it that the king would adorn himself
in gold annually as part
of a renewal ceremony
and then he would bath in a lake.
And many who will think that this is
the origin of the myth of El Dorado
but as you'll see El Dorado
gets located much further away,
not 50 years later.
When I talk about El Dorado,
I'm also indexing other kinds
of narratives of treasure and I
know that I have green hell here,
that should really say
green hell or paradise.
Because depending on your
perspective it could be either.
So I'm talking about the
idea of an earthly paradise
which Europeans were also
seeking in the new world.
I'm talking about our Garden
of Eden, a land of plenty
or opportunity or in the
words of Voltaire's Candide,
the best of all possible worlds.
After ten months of
fruitless voyaging Pizarro
and his crew found themselves
entering an unknown forested valley.
Hungry and dangerously low on
supplies, the party stopped,
sending captain Francisco de
Orellana down the Coca River.
With a small crew in
search of salvation.
The small crew was completely
unprepared for the size and force
of the [inaudible] or so
they would later report.
This along with their utter
ignorance of the terrain,
a green hell by some accounts.
Combined to make a
return journey impossible.
Instead Orellana and his men
journeyed down river to the east.
Completing the first fully
recorded decent of the Amazon River.
And I think it's crucial
here that Orellana
and his men were not planning
to do this and didn't know
where they were going to end up.
Because the narrative that
we get from the journals,
even though it falls in the genre of
survival literature, is free of some
of the ethnological thinking,
protoethnological thinking
that later structures
narratives of this place.
It would be another 100
years before anybody was able
to complete the journey and it
was done in the opposite direction
and the narrative that we get
then isn't June 21st we stop
for food, people were friendly.
It sounds more like, well
these are the people,
these are their customs,
this is how they eat.
And so instantly the Amazon, that
is a place the size of Europe,
is reduced to a single
point in time.
And all of the people that live
in it and all of the landscapes,
are equalized and this
is what sticks.
The term green hell by the way comes
from a narrative by a historian,
some say a very well,
I would say to sort
of dubious reliability
named Garcilaso de la Vega.
He was born just about the time that
the voyage was departing in 1540
and he was writing 60 years later.
And he was gathering not
only accounts of this voyage
but of several other voyages
and he was writing a history
of the kingdom of Peru.
And his work comes up later
because he was paying attention
to other things that
were being reported
and then he gets cited as well.
So part of what I'm doing, even
though I'm looking at images
and I'm looking at maps, is I'm
tracing how these ideas flow
from one place to another.
So, not long after that, we
get an early map of the Amazon,
now this isn't the first one that
I found but it's interesting.
Because it's the first
one that I found here
and this is here by the way.
That has the earliest
one I should say,
that has not just a
representation of the river
and it's course more or less.
But it also has images of people,
right and actually this fantastic
snake like representation
of the river appears
over and over again.
But I just want to call your
attention to what's happening right
in the middle of the scene, which
is the scene of cannibalism.
Even though the only story of
cannibalism that people had
at the time was from the shorelines.
They've located this in the Amazon.
What's happening on the
shorelines is still maybe something
to be considered primitive,
we have hunting people
live in huts or tents.
But the cannibals are
in that unknown place.
So now let's look,
systematically at some of these maps
and what I've done is
I've split them up,
we're just going to
look at two periods.
Because they have different
patterns to them.
So this is the earliest map that
is in the Library of Congress.
And one of the things
I love about it,
is that it's actually very
true to what people knew.
We don't have the whole
outline of the continent,
we know the river is huge.
We know that it goes from
Iquitos which is in the mountains
to the ocean and that's
all that we have.
And the names of all the
tributaries or peoples.
So, even though the outline
isn't great it's actually,
one of the more accurate early maps
in terms of what it represents,
what it presents to the world.
And then we get at the
other end of the spectrum,
a map by Giacomo Gastaldi
and we think that it's his
and that it was made some
time between 1550 and 1556.
None of his maps were signed
but it's been attributed to him.
And he's done some interesting
things, the river flows north
to the south or rather
south to north.
Iquitos is kind of right next to
the coast, so he wasn't working
with particularly good notes
but it's a very pretty map,
with lots of mountains.
Most of which aren't
where he's put them.
The other thing that he's done
that I haven't seen in any
of the maps before 1590, is that
he's got the Castillo del Oro,
the castle of gold at
the very top of the map,
you'll see that in the closeup.
And it's the only one
that I've found here
where that's actually
mapped some place.
And the practice of mapping things,
even though people don't know
where they are was
actually quite prevalent.
Which I suppose I should
have expected.
And then as a sort of
middle of the road map,
we get this very very busy map again
with an unknown author,
of unknown authorship.
And there's no mention
of any gold castles,
we have I think slightly
better river courses
so he's got a little
bit more information.
Probably some things coming
from the Portuguese at one end
and from the Peruvians on the other
or from Iquitos at the other end.
But a lot of these early maps are
almost illegible because they're
so busy and they're so full
of wind roses and flags.
But it's interesting to see
that that's what's important.
What's important is that there are
cities and anytime someone mentions
of people, this author has drawn a
castle, which I think is amazing.
Because that goes away very quickly.
So initially it was just assumed
that these were all civilizations
that built castles, just
like they have in Europe
and so they have their flags and
they have the name of the king.
So, that is very different
from what I expected to find.
So then I asked myself
what happened?
Right, what changed?
Because when you get to the 1590's
and I actually think this map isn't
from 1590 which is what's
listed here I think it's from,
it almost has to be from after 1595
and I'll tell you why in a second,
I hate to mysterious
but no I love it.
Is that we get the, the Parime lake
which I've tried to highlight here
and again a slightly
closer view of it.
Which is the lake of gold.
And it's in the Guianas, it
might also be referenced as Manao
but it's the first time that
it appears in this place.
And then it just appears in
all of the maps after that.
Right up until 1750,
possibly beyond.
Right around then, around 1748
people start being a little bit more
cautious so, some of the authors
like Guillaume Sanson will
still represent the lake and try
to give it a size, the dimension
and put it amongst mountains
as the description suggests and some
of them will just say well here's
where I would put the lake of gold
if I was sure that it was here.
But it's interesting that they
don't, they don't just exclude it,
they say this is where some people
say the lake of gold exists.
And that happens in
several languages,
it happens in several editions.
So it's a practice, it's
people beginning to think
about representing things
in maps in a different way.
So what happens at the
end of the 16th century
that has changed the way that
these representations occur.
Well apparently Sir
Walter Raleigh happened.
He journeyed from England, he was
very desperate to gain the favors
of the crown, he was
desperate to find this place.
And he writes this narrative of
going to northern South America
to the Guianas and searching for
this lake and talking to people
and what we actually think happened
is that he talked to a Spaniard,
some Spaniards who'd
been there longer
and gotten these narratives
from indigenous peoples.
And they were telling him that
yes there is a lake of gold
and lies just beyond the mountains.
And there's actually been some
interesting archeological done,
work done to think about why these
stories of gold were happening here.
But it's also interesting to
note that people are talking
about gold coming from
this place called Manao all
over northern South America.
And we do know that there
were extensive trade fruits
that crisscrossed northern
South America at that time,
the time that Europeans
came so, it's conceivable
that it was just the case of
someone saying oh it's just
over the mountain, things
actually being a lot further away.
Needless to say no such lake exists
but there is a marshland there
that when it's flooded,
semiannually might look a little bit
like Sir Walter Raleigh's
representation
of the map which I didn't put in.
Sorry. So how, so Sir
Walter Raleigh happened
and what's so important about him?
The only thing that's
important about him is
that everybody was reading him.
He was considered one of the
greatest sort of trappers,
he was given prominence
in his writing,
as someone who had been there.
And at the time people that
have traveled were given credit
for things and Richard Hakluyt
actually explicitly acknowledges Sir
Walter Raleigh as the person
from whom he received his
most reliable information.
So Richard Hakluyt founded
the Hakluyt Society,
he wrote the Principal Navigation's
and he was very highly regarding
and endorsing Sir Walter Raleigh.
He basically backed things that he
said and that has to be the reason
that everybody puts the lake
where they do even though
no one ever sees it,
for as long as they do.
Some also suggest that people
were reading Garcilaso de la Vega
and particularly his accounts of
cannibalism, which is something
that we might come back to.
Depending on the time.
The other thing I wanted
to point out is that,
at the time that these authors
were constructing these maps,
maps were full of monsters
and writing full
of monsters and that was normal.
Right I mean we're talking
about 1550's up to 1650,
we're in a premodern science
context, prescientific paradigm.
So it's not surprising that some
of these maps contain
these fantastical elements.
What is surprising is
that even though we know
that fairytales don't exist today,
that we still locate
them in the Amazon.
And that they survived you
know a couple of centuries
of pretty rigorous scientific
thought, how did this happen?
So I draw upon the work of Linda
Tuhiwai Smith's specifically
for this but also of people
that study travel writing
like Mary Louise Pratt, her work
on how the intellectual movements
of the enlightenment
sort of solidified a lot
of these ideas as really important.
But I also draw a lot upon Neil
Whitehead who was a historian,
a anthropologist and
historiographer of the Amazon.
But this idea circulation
that I use substantially,
particularly in this article,
comes from Linda Tuhiwai
Smith who is a Maori Scholar.
And one of the things she says is
that distance is very important
in constructing these narratives.
These two images of the Amazon,
the green hell and El Dorado
or if you want to call
them the optimistic
and pessimistic narrative,
they became the basis
for future understandings
of Amazonia.
Which was one of these
really far away places
and I think it's really
important that there was a year
in between the first decent
of the Amazon and the second.
Because that gave people a
lot of time to refigure some
of these early narratives and
write them into their ideas
of what the place could and couldn't
support and eventually what it meant
to be savaged or I think the
cannibalistic narratives kind
of helped in that and what
it meant to be civilized.
So it's interesting that Amazonia
and maybe a couple of other places
in the world still have
these mythical reputations,
because a lot of places
were far away back then.
And so we're going to come
back to this but the discourse
of the inhabitability
or the underlying notion
of uninhabitability is very
important to this as well.
But let's just think about
how these ideas were created,
so a set of people
set off on a journey.
They collected data and wrote some
narratives which were then sent back
to Europe where they
were read by scholars,
recirculated exchanged, resignified.
Particularly if you're talking about
from 1650 onward people are starting
to try to systematize the Earth,
Europeans are creating systems
of taxonomy, they're getting
better understandings of geography,
they're understanding longitude,
they're creating better maps.
And they're trying to create systems
of order or ordering the world.
And so what happens is that these
archetypal images of people come
into being and they also, they
come into being not just along
with images of places but in
the context of images of places.
I was really shocked at the
length of the discussion
that Charles Marie de La
Condamine who's pictured here,
who was sent off to measure the
equator, he was a cartographer.
The amount of time that he
spent talking about things
like the Amazons and El Dorado it
seems an inordinately long amount
of time but evidently this was
something that had to be grappled
with in terms of the order
that was being constructed
and it also functioned
in that order.
I argue that places like
the Amazon where the foil
against which civilization
was constructed.
Oh, I always forget to say this.
These ideas of El Dorado and
green hell they still circulate
and not just in the media.
But also in anthropological
and archeological text.
El Dorado was sited just in 2001.
So.
Places were co-constructed
with subjects.
And this is the opposition
that we're left with.
And one of the things
that I've noticed is
that those ideas still exist.
Except today's green hell
isn't uncontacted tribes,
although occasionally that becomes
part of the lost paradise narrative.
It's deforestation.
It's burning, it's the lose
of the atmospheric carbon sink
and on the other side of the
coin, we have this green jungle,
the optimism for life, the
exuberance people going to try
to name species or discover curious
pharmacological research and as late
as earlier last century
there was a lot of sort
of mining going on in the area.
So there was a lot of optimism,
there's a very old idea
that the tropics produce
everything in excess
and I think that's something that
continues to be carried through.
The other thing that I get
from Linda Tuhiwai Smith is
this really important connection
that she makes and I think
other scholars make too,
with the idea of property.
And I think she's not pointing out
the property issue but she's looking
at Locke and he says that as
much land that man tills, plants,
improves or cultivates
and can use the products
of so much is his property.
So essentially if you're an
agriculturist then you can claim
property and be civilized.
And one of the problems
that Europeans have faced
over the centuries in the Amazon
is that they can't seem to tame it.
Many projects have tried and failed,
the Portuguese initially tried
to setup what they considered to be
functional colonies, growing cotton,
the soils of the Amazon are
not appropriate for this,
we're going to be looking
at that in a second.
But at the same time there's this
idea that you have to be able
to master nature in
order to be civilized.
And if Europeans insisted on seeing
the Amazonian jungle as pristine,
then of course they could never
have mastered that nature.
And I think at the root of
this idea of this excessive
and exuberant nature that can't be
mastered and this is just an idea
because as the archeological
narrative shows it has been
and can be.
This is the route of both the green
hell and the paradise narrative.
And as soon as we take
down that notion,
then both of those images collapse.
So if we go back to the
idea of an untouched jungle,
we know that no longer exists.
And it's also not worth
preserving which is something
that we should think
about for the future.
But it also means that there
have been different ways
of managing the landscape
that weren't agrarian.
And that is what the
archeological narrative shows us.
So I'm not going to get into
this idea about the plough
but there's a very clear connection
between agriculture and society.
This comes from Hobbes's De Cive
on civility on civilization.
And on the one side we have
imperium which is order
and there are people
farming and on the other side
of course we have the natives
they're based on American images,
right sort of native
American's or savaged peoples.
And not only are they
brandishing bows and hunting
but they're also just off
to the side of the picture,
there's a cannibal, there's a
scene of cannibalism happening.
So there's a very clear
opposition between agriculture
and not an agriculture and
there's a closeup of that.
So these oppositions that are setup
in the merging scientific narratives
get picked up in other language
and anthropological thought.
Particularly the narrative
about agriculture.
One of the things that is
crucial to the development
of complex societies,
which is the archeological
or anthropological version
of the idea of civilization,
is that people must be able to
produce an agricultural surplus,
if it's impossible to produce
an agricultural surplus
or if those peoples haven't
engineered technologies
that could produce an
agricultural surplus,
then there is no wealth
to be amassed.
And then there can be no inequality
and then there can be no dominion,
no kingship, no social hierarchy.
So social complexity and
anthropology is based entirely
on the idea that a complex society
has multiple levels of hierarchy.
Which is also a notion that's been
challenged and yet people continue
to do research in the Amazon and
in other places that aren't suited
to monocultures particularly
looking for the staple crop.
Which is an idea that really only
makes sense in tempered climates.
So again, the narrative persists.
And I just wanted to point out,
I pulled this up yesterday.
That sometimes the
image of the green hell
and the lost paradise coexists.
And I think they particularly
coexist in these kinds of stories
that pull up images of so
called uncontacted tribes
that were discovered in the Amazon.
And I had a quote from the story,
but essentially National Geographic
sensationalizes this image
of what they call tribal warriors
looking up in alarm at a plane
that flew over their camp which
is something that isn't suppose
to happen with uncontacted tribes.
And just to clarify because
the stuff has come up.
The unconcated tribe isn't a
tribe that hasn't been contacted,
it's a tribe that at least in
the Brazilian government speech,
that there has been an agreement
that people will be
limiting contact.
So it's not that people don't
know that these independent,
sovereign tribes exist,but
there has been an agreement
that there will not be commerce
of any kind social or otherwise
in between government
agents and the tribes.
And so when you see a picture
like this it's not a savage coming
into contact with the modern
world, we're not looking
at something that's frozen in time.
This is a breach of a
contract that's being filmed.
So let's get the story straight.
And I do like to talk about
the tyranny of the plough
because I think at least in
archeology we have become slaves
to the idea that we have to find
agricultural societies in order
to find civilization, which is also
code for interesting places to work.
And so if you don't have evidence
of metallurgy, big temples
or monumental architecture and mass
agriculture then people often think
that there's nothing to research.
And what Amazonian
archeologists have been showing
for the last 30 years is
that they're very wrong.
And so I'm going to talk quickly,
Jason how we doing on time?
Okay. I'm going to talk
quickly about Terra Preta
which is sometimes translated to
English as indigenous black earth
and this is a term that's used
in Brazil very commonly
[foreign language] means
that it's a black soil
that was of the Indian,
right of the indigenous person
but also made by those people.
And I think that's really important
to point out and so when people talk
about indigenous black
earth I don't think
that really captures
the full meaning.
What do we know about Terra Preta?
That is a carbon and
nutrient-rich soil.
That is always associated with
large amounts of occupational debris
so there's a lot of
ceramics and sometimes fawn
of remains or remains of bones.
Occasionally human remains
as well and plant remains.
And usually very very very dense,
scatters of these things if you look
at the image on the right, with
the archeologists trowel laying
out on what looks like rocks,
those are all ceramic sherds
and that's a undisturbed piece
of land that we just walked on.
They're often situated on bluffs
that's not particularly interesting
I think anymore, but
what's really interesting is
that they're more stable and
less acidic than oxisols.
And oxisols are the dominant soils
in the central Amazon where I work,
they're slightly different
classifications for a lot
of the soils, right near the Amazon
but most of them are very oxidized,
they're very old, they can
be up two million years old.
And these sites often
have earthworks and some
of them are very large and
some of them are very small.
And I'm going to talk a little bit
about what you might call medium
sized, house sized earthworks.
Why do we care about Terra Preta?
Well if you look at the
dominant Amazonian soil,
to the right the oxisol, there's
less than five centimeters of humus.
And most of that if you
clear cut that land,
goes away within a year or two.
And even if you don't
you're not going
to get very good return
for planting there.
So farmers recognize when
they see at the Terra Preta
that they're going to get much
better returns from farming.
Also the deep root
the Terra Preta is,
the longer people have
inhabited that space.
There's no correlation in
terms of inches or centimeters,
depth and time but, something
that I think, that's about 50
or 60 centimeters deep is probably
a very long term occupation
and when we have hiatus's
we now understand
that there are different kinds
of soils that intervenes,
so that is a continuous occupation.
And I'm going to show you the site
that I worked for my dissertation
and it only has about
20 centimeters of soil
and I think we're looking
at 800 years.
So, this site and I think
is [foreign language].
We know we're looking at something
that started around 500 BC
and went right up until
just about contact.
Stability is the other thing.
So not only are these
soils more nutrient-rich
but the can be farmed
for longer periods.
So even if you clear cut and do a
monoculture on a Terra Preta soil
which isn't recommended, you
can still farm that soil for up
to ten years, opposed
to two to three.
Sometimes people stretch it to five
but they're really not
getting very much return
for their labor when they do that.
So, at the top, on the
right, is one of the densest,
darkest Terra Preta
sites that I have worked
on in the central Amazon.
It is I believe at least
30 hectares in size,
they're are very large mounds
some of which are funerary,
some of which we haven't
quite understood yet.
And if you look at the bottom
that site [foreign language]
has been farmed in this way
with several monocultures
for over 25 years.
I will say that we know that
the current owner does use soil
amendments but the advantage is
that they don't get
washed into the river.
Which is what usually happens if
you use NPK or potash those sorts
of things on regular
Amazonian soils,
so another bonus for
the environment.
So, why do we care about, what
do I care about Terra Preta,
I think archaeologically
there's lots of reasons to care.
They emerge all across the
Amazon, very quickly it seems
to be phenomenon that spreads from
one end of the Amazon to the other
in the space of a couple
hundred years.
By about 1100 AD, there are massive
sites with palisades and earthworks
at several of the major
crossroads, so we have a technology
that has spread and yet
we have different kinds
of ceramic traditions
which indicates different,
at the very least different
stylistic ideas or creative trends
and potentially different
ethnicities if you look
at the distances on a map.
It's not absurd to
think that we're talking
about different ethnicities
using the same sets of practices.
So what it represents is the
tremendous change in the way
that humans are relating
to the environment.
And one of the key
questions that people have is,
well did they know
what they were doing?
And so it's something that I've
been researching and I think
that the best answer is
that initially they didn't
and at some point they
figured it out.
Because there are some groups in
the Amazon today that make a sort
of Terra Preta to use as
gardens intentionally.
Some of them are indigenous
and some of them are what we
in Brazil call traditional
farming groups
which is an officially recognized
government category of people
that have been inhabiting the
Amazon for a certain number of years
and have a different way of
interacting with each other
and with Brazilian civil society.
Then Brazilians would but they
aren't necessarily indigenous
because of shifting populations
and there's a lot going on there
but let's just say multiethnic
communities that live
in the forest using some
traditional practices and some
of which might have been learned
from indigenous populations
or a throop heredity.
I'm interested in how
these things were formed
at the level the individual.
Because I think that if we can
find out how people were able
to make the soil then, it
shouldn't be that hard to replicate.
It is hard to figure
out how they did it.
And so what I did, was I
appealed to soil science.
And I also started studying the
way that, that sites were made
in the present, so as
people inhabit a space,
what are the kinds of
things that happen?
What is the evidence of these
everyday repeated actions
which we call practices?
And one of the things that one
of my mentors pointed out is
that these earth ovens, in
this case it's a brick oven
but usually they're earth ovens.
That people use create a
certain kind of charcoal,
that's a really important
ingredient in Terra Preta.
And so that was the first thing
that I noticed that made me think
that maybe we should be
studying more than the soil
but also the things
that are in the soil.
So normally a soil
science will take,
soil scientist will take a soil
sample and grind it up and put
into a machine and analyze it.
And what I did with a host
of undergraduate students,
there were more than 20
people helping me in the lab,
was we didn't crush the
samples, we separated everything
and we analyzed all the little
bits of the things that were
in these soils to try to
understand what were the things
that contributed to the formation of
Terra Preta and what are the things
that told us what people
were doing at any given time
on a particular piece of a site.
And we're talking I was looking, I
was comparing areas about the size
of this room, so medium to
large house areas to each other.
And so in addition to looking
at tiny pieces of charcoal
or charred plant remains we also
ended up looking at tiny tiny pieces
of ceramics or burnt clay which
might have come from ovens.
They would've looked
different from this one but,
we've excavated some things that
look a little bit like earth ovens.
Moving right along bio-char is
the most important ingredient
for Terra Preta because
it's very very stable.
And it also holds onto
other kinds of nutrients.
If you put bio-char together
with little pieces of bone,
appetite then you get
an extremely strong bond
that makes these soils
even more fertile,
so it's important not only
people were burning things
but they were cooking.
Right or that they
were burning garbage
that contained animal remains,
probably cooking would've happened
in the unintentional scenario
and the burning garbage
with animal remains in
the intentional scenario.
Right so initially people
would've figured it out
and then they would've started
doing the intentional burning.
So I'm looking, this is from
my friend Morgan Schmidt's work
with the Kuikuru Indians
in upper Xingu,
they make middens intentionally,
they cultivate them in the sense
that they order the way
that they dispose of garbage
and then they will use certain parts
of the middens as gardens depending
on how long they've
been sort of simmering.
And so here we have banana trees
and lemon trees and lime trees,
things that wouldn't be
growing on Amazonian soils,
growing right in peoples backyards.
Very quickly this is the village,
the orange blobs are houses
and the things behind them are the
middens, the mounds of dark earth
that people use for gardens.
So in the central Amazon,
there's lots of beautiful pottery.
I did a study like this at a
site that consisted of 12 mounds
that we thought were houses.
We excavated them and we found
out that did seem [inaudible]
to be constructed underneath the
platform which is the clay floor
that has the horizontal lines.
Is a very charcoal rich soil
which I initially thought would be
like a Terra Preta but
upon analysis realized
that that was a garden soil.
Some of the houses had gardens
underneath them and some
of the houses had other
houses underneath them.
Plotting this spatially.
I'm sorry to move so fast I get a
sequence of occupation so we started
with one house, that house
eventually sprouted other houses
and these houses were starting
to be built on platforms.
We're not exactly sure why yet.
But eventually the entire landscape
and this is a circumscribed
peninsula
that was entirely taken
up by houses.
Right up to the flood line.
And so what happens when you
circumscribe people on a piece
of land and you're depositing all of
your garbage next to your houses is
that you get very very
rich soils, very quickly.
And so I recently published
an article that demonstrates
that this is how the soils
were transformed suddenly
through a combination of population
growth and circumscription.
They overwhelmed the ecosystem
and transformed what would
have been a very sterile soil
into a very productive soil.
This demonstrates that
people were instrumental
in instigating ecological change but
that in this case they didn't seem
to be doing it on purpose.
That they were there for several
hundred years, so I don't know
if you caught the chronology but
we're going from about 300 to 500 AD
to 800 AD, so that's 500 years.
And that they were investing
in constructing this landscape
in a particular way
in spite of the fact
that they were sacrificing
their farmland.
And so evidently farmland
wasn't terribly important.
So if you think about the way
people occupied space then and think
about the way people occupy space
now, we might be able to come
up with better strategies
for managing the Amazon.
Very quickly going back to
the picture of the village,
what I want to emphasize
is that as long
as someone is inhabiting this
space, they're going to be invested
in thinking about how
to make it better.
As long as were just using it
and extracting things from it,
for the purposes of
the outside world,
then we have no chance
of preserving it.
So thinking about the Amazon
as a global carbon sink,
might help in the short run but
isn't really particularly helpful
in thinking about how
we inhabit the Amazon.
I don't know whether I should
tell everybody to go live there,
probably not, but I think that
the solution is the project
that I'm running now or one
potential solution is to work
with communities independently
to see how they manage their
landscapes, see what we can offer
in terms of archaeological
evidence, archaeological narratives,
tactics to try to help them
create a better management system
so that their growing
populations can be well articulated
with this very complex ecosystem.
That doesn't respond well
to [inaudible] cultural.
So, all that being said,
thank you to all of the people
that made this possible
including all of you.
And I'm through.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Two minutes for questions?
Two minutes for questions.
Yes?
>> What happen after 800?
You said this was going
from 300 to 800 AD?
>> Anna Brown Ribeiro: So we
actually think it went on until 1100
but we don't have a date for 1100.
But that's when most of the sites
in that area stopped being
inhabited or they changed hands.
And so we actually think
happened is this case is
that a different group
moved in up river.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Well I, so I think what
I'm trying to say is,
that in that particular case,
Terra Preta stopped being produced
and we think it's because a
different group moved in from upper
and they didn't have those
practices that created the soils,
they actually, we actually that
they took some of these mounds
and they took them
down and spread them
out to create larger
agricultural fields.
So these are people that were
coming from the south and east
and they were moving through.
And we have some evidence for
warfare that suggests that.
If you go to the Madeira River,
just down the river and then
up a little bit, we actually
have Terra Preta that's being
manufactured up until 1700.
Along with ceramics that are
continuous with this tradition.
So in some parts of the
Amazon the practice continued.
But so much, the population
were so destructuralized
after European encounter,
particularly because of disease,
that it's very hard to
pinpoint where that came from
and the group that's in the upper
Shengru we're fairly certain have
nothing to do with these groups
that were in the central Amazon.
And so, again I'm thinking about
this is a kind of technology
that spread and can
be utilized again.
[ Inaudible Question ]
So I you said conference
or conflict?
Either? Yeah I.
I have not seen any
specific references in text
and if you have I would
love to see them.
I do think it's very clear
that in the Amazon the
[inaudible] were also trying
to create little replicas of
good Spanish or Portuguese towns
with peasants that
had particular jobs
and they had these very rich
realized ways of instituting sort
of village status replace and
creating rectilinear streets.
They had these prescriptions
for establishing settlements
that envisioned a particular kind
of landscape that they wanted
to reproduce in the Amazon.
And the idea that there
were this exuberant nature,
made it seem eminently possible.
But the thing that they weren't able
to understand I think
was two things.
First of all that there had been
no impetuous to agriculture before
so a lot of the peoples that they
were trying to convince to come live
in these towns had no
interest in living in them.
They had no interest in
wages, they had no interested
in tilling the land and of
course it was a fruitless venture
in most places in the Amazon.
I mean we see it happening towards
the Vazia [assumed spelling],
which is actually sorry
towards the flood plane area,
let me speak English.
In the [inaudible] area, which
is again a different Amazon
but as we move up river it
becomes virtually impossible
and you constantly see
letters written to Europe
of people complaining, oh I
can't keep the neophytes here,
they keep running away, I need more
labor, can we have different rules
for descending Indians, can we
go and try to find other people
and some of these are,
you know there's good
and the bad and the ugly.
But there's definitely this,
this idea that's being pushed
and they're running up
against all kinds of,
there's an incommensurability
between what they expect to see
and what they envision as
good earth, good earth is one
of the things that they
site, oh this is good earth,
this is bad earth as they go down,
this is good country,
this is bad country.
And what ideas that already
existed about what as a good way
to inhabit the landscape
and what was fruitful.
>> Jason Steinhauer: I
think we'll just stop there.
Please join me in thanking Anna.
[ Applause ]
And just a quick announcement.
We are back here on the 26th of
January which is actually a Tuesday.
Unusual for us as we're
usually on Thursday's,
but on Tuesday the 26th
we have the privilege
of welcoming back our most recent
Maguire Chair, David Hollenbach
to deliver the annual
Maguire Address.
He'll be discussing ethical
responsibilities towards refugees
and people displaced by war.
So if you are interested
in that, please join us.
Please sign our email list
on the way out to learn
about upcoming events
and please join me again
in thanking Anna for her talk today.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.